[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans son street uniforme de 1940 le
Général de Gaulle a reçu de la foule
athénienne un accueil inoubliable entre
les deux haies populaires qui lui criait
leur amitié le président de la
République aux côtés du roi Paul a fait
son entrée dans sa tête et peut-être cet
accueillanthousiaste s'explique-t-il par
la fraternité mais du passé de deux pays
qui furent les berceaux de la
civilisation et de la liberté
cette visite à la famille royale de
Grèce avait dès les premiers mots
déterminés son sens face à un avenir
chargé d'inquiétude et d'espoir la
France et la Grèce veulent conjuguer
leurs efforts
ce sens de la rencontre le général de
Gaulle de vélo confirmer dans cette
sorte de pèlerinage aux sources de
l'humanisme occidental devant l'Acropole
devant les vestiges dorés qui retracent
la marche en avant de l'esprit humain
puisqu'il s'est appelé d'abord praxitel
et selon Phidias et Platon Homère et
Aristote
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'accueil des villages de la tique fut
égal à celui de la capitale
au milieu de ces groupes de paysans et
d'ouvriers le général de Gaulle refit le
geste qu'il fait en France se mêlant
simplement à la foule grecque comme il
se met au Full français
[Musique]
mais la grande leçon de ce voyage devait
se dégager à Salonique d'abord au
cimetière militaire où dorment de leur
dernier sommeil plus de 8000 soldats
français tombés sur le sol grec pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale signé
mouvant d'une fraternité d'armes qui
s'ajoute à la fraternité de culture et
d'esprit
ensuite au cours du grand défilé qui
unissait les marins français aux unités
helléniques de toutes armes
c'était là l'illustration vivante de la
déclaration qui avait faite devant le
parlement grec le général de Gaulle
votre défense c'est l'anneau si nous
appartenons vous et nous à l'Alliance
atlantique c'est avec la conviction
qu'il n'y a pas pour les peuples libres
d'autres garanties de la paix
[Applaudissements]
sans doute faudra-t-il encore du temps
pour que dans le sud des États-Unis les
problèmes ratiaux perdent leur acuité
actuelle la population noire n'a pas
renoncé à ces manifestations contre la
ségrégation et toutes ne se sont pas
achevés avec la même simplicité dans les
cartes de la police
comme à burmingham en Alabama les
manifestants noirs qui s'étaient réunis
devant les restaurants ségrégationnistes
n'ont pas cédé la place sans résistance
[Applaudissements]
la présence des forces fédérales
envoyées par le président Kennedy
marquera-t-elle définitivement le
commencement de la sagesse elle
préviendra on l'espère le retour de ses
affrontements tragiques entre les deux
populations
les Cormerais directeur de la
cinématographie française a bien voulu
honorer d'une particulière attention les
travaux du 18e congrès de la Fédération
Nationale des Cinémas Français avant
leur entrée en séance les délégués se
sont-ils fait prédire par cette jeune
vedette l'avenir du cinéma et ses
délicats rapports avec la télévision
[Musique]
tandis que la fusée Atlas brillait sous
les projecteurs de Cap Canaveral Gordon
Cooper s'apprêtait à vivre la grande
aventure de l'espace il refaisait un à
un les gestes qui avaient fait les cinq
américains venus avant lui à ce
rendez-vous du petit matin je sais pas
Grison Glenn Carpenter et
[Musique]
cette fois dans la capsule Mercury
tapissé de cadran coupeur devait passer
près de 34 heures le temps de boucler 22
fois le tour de la terre l'aube Solvay
quand ça cheval compte à rebours
toute l'Amérique pu suivre les images
transmises indirecte de Cap Canaveral de
la miss sur orbite du 10e homme de
l'espace
si les 22 révolutions de Gordon Cooper
furent sans histoire il n'en a pas même
du retour dans l'atmosphère le contrôle
automatique était en panne d'un
porte-avion croisant au sud du Japon
Glenn suivait seconde par seconde les
opérations sur ces indications coupeur
alluma lui-même les rétrofusés de
freinage les largas puis opéra sa
stabilisation
opération capital puisque faute
d'aborder la couche atmosphérique dans
l'angle voulu la cabine risquée de
fondre
à 7000 mètres le premier parachute de
freinage souverain normalement
[Musique]
à 3500 mètres le grand parachute se
déployait à son tour mieux la cabine de
Cooper touchait la mer à moins de 4 km
du porte-avion chargé avec 27 autres
navires et 172 avions de la récupérer
grands succès pour la mairie et Gordon
Cooper avait bien mérité le surnom de
cosmonaute tranquille que le monde lui a
donné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Saint Pierre et Miquelon donnons
inséparables qui chantent dans la
mémoire depuis l'école c'est aussi à
4000 km de Paris 240 km² de France c'est
même un coin de Bretagne et de Pays
Basque réunis sous les brouillards de
Terre-Neuve le roi de Grande-Bretagne
dit le traité de Paris la restituer en
1763 à Sa Majesté très chrétienne pour
servir d'abris aux pêcheurs français
juste deux siècles plus tard toujours
gardiques par ces quatre canons de
bronze Saint-Pierre la capitale qui
groupe 4500 et 5000 habitants de
l'archipel n'est pas autre chose
aujourd'hui qu'importe de pêche délaissé
par les équipages français
[Musique]
un unique navire le micro assure la
liaison avec le Canada
un modeste aérodrome
ignorait des Boeing et autres caravelles
mais son orgueil dans ses appareils de 3
et 4 places
la station radio est bien défendue avis
aux mauvais coupscheurs qui en aurait
contre Dalida ou Johnny Hallyday
les chemins ici ne viennent de nulle
part et ne vont qu'à Saint-Pierre un
panneau n'en annonce pas moins l'entrée
de la cité
construite en bois à la mode canadienne
Saint-Pierre il faut le dire à la
passion des panneaux elle en possède
trois qui interdisent le stationnement
au même endroit ou à peu près et une
belle collection de sens interdit
on se croirait à Paris à cette
différence près que le contractuel local
c'est toujours obstinément refusé
adresser la moindre contravention aux
rares automobilistes
[Musique]
un coin de France comme tant d'autres
avec ses 11 gendarmes chargés d'assurer
le respect de la loi encore qu'on n'est
pas ici le souvenir d'un seul petit
crime un détail pourtant les îles ont
leur mené c'est que Saint Pierre et
Miquelon ne forment pas un département
mais un territoire d'outre-mer avec à
leur tête un administrateur à ses côtés
un député un sénateur 14 conseillers
généraux un maire fidèle au béret basque
et un président du syndicat d'initiative
avec une température moyenne de 5 degrés
la vie n'est pas particulièrement douce
pour les habitants l'activité tourne
autour de l'élevage des animaux à
fourrure renard bleu et renard argenté
qui peut encore prendre une certaine
extension
[Musique]
comme l'élevage du vison qui s'est
nettement affirmé depuis une quinzaine
d'années mais c'est surtout la mer qui
demeure la vraie dispensatrice des
ressources
la mer si essentielle et si présente que
les tombes du cimetière ont des hublots
pour permettre aux morts de l'entendre
encore
qui reste le seul à venir de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon le port moderne
dont la construction est envisagée
ramènera les équipages français sur ces
grèves aujourd'hui fréquentées par des
bandes de chevaux que leurs oisifs thé a
rendu à l'état sauvage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]